[Music]
this is Mew and me it's automatic games
for cats
um let me try that again this is Mew and
me it's the first collection of games
designed just for cats that's meant to
be left on when you're away from home
the games automatically cycle throughout
the day and try to figure out what your
cat likes best and the best part is once
you come home it shows you what your cat
has been up to so um yeah that's you and
me games for cats facts for people
[Music]
boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Don sake and
very excited to be talking about the
heroic power of games conscious
gamification taking a stronger emotional
tie with our animals and understanding
the science behind all of this we have
will delve into all joining us on the
show hello hello thanks for coming on
absolutely did it I'm very grateful we
met at Ross Science Film Festival and
that we are now able to unpack your
journey in this field this is a lot of
fun very much I'm excited yes yes for
those who don't know Williams background
will him spent four years doing software
engineering with Lumosity he has now for
the last year and a half
been doing as the founder and CEO of Miu
and me working on this project also is
very fascinated with conscious
gamification the heroic power of games
so we're gonna be unpacking that so all
the links are below to immune me as well
as Williams website go check it out his
Instagram will and let's start things
off with this big history perspective we
find ourselves as stewards of Earth what
is your current take on the state of
humanity that is such a big question so
I think that basically we at least as a
country are in one of the most polarized
time periods we've been in a long time
and I think that the the biggest thing
that we're lacking is empathy basically
an emotional perspective it's it's what
I consider my greatest strength is being
able to be emotional and it is also what
I consider to be the next step in human
evolution as you love to talk about I
think that especially for men
we've spent a long time being told to
suppress our emotions and I got
extremely lucky to grow up in an
artistic family I had two theatre
professors as parents so emotions were
always on the forefront and now that I'm
in the working world and especially in a
design framework I have found that
emotions are one of my greatest
strengths so I basically think that we
could all be a little more emotional
yeah that is extremely powerful I agree
with you totally on the vulnerability
side of things and the importance that
that actually has in both working on
one's own self
work this sincere process of developing
oneself is being able to express oneself
emotionally really well at the same time
as what it does for the communities of
people around us and we're able to
completely open up and talk about what's
going on in our lives it's a that's
that's it's a lot of of importance there
also when you want to address you can
look over here too yeah got it on this
yeah okay so on that emotion side of
things there's this there's this part of
our world and I like to kind of think
about it like a bell curve there's like
a vast majority of people just want
peace and dignity and stuff a lot of
people want like activism they're like
constantly fighting for that piece of
dignity and then kind of like the
malevolent people that are the ones that
are making it so that we have these
trillion dollars in budgets of
militaries and stuff trying to fend off
these like I'm 11 people and it's just a
bunch of ignorance that needs to be
cured now where do you see you know this
increase in emotion and empathy taking
in to play with these 8 billion people
and these tribes of countries how does
that end up taking us towards progress
yeah another big question another good
question
so what I'm seeing I am very much like I
said I've been in games pretty much my
whole life and I've been in products as
well at least almost as long and where
I'm seeing it most is our perspective on
capitalism so a lot of the we can talk
about this more in a second a lot of my
own inspiration comes from the group
conscious capitalism basically it just
makes intuitive sense that if the people
that you are paying money to don't feel
like there have your best interests at
heart then you know you're not going to
want to work with them and as our world
becomes more and more tech savvy being
able to hide that being able to hide the
fact that you are manipulating are you
abusing your workers or your users or
whoever is just more difficult so you
know we're moving towards a place where
the companies that genuinely care and
genuinely do good are being empowered it
is what I see as the the largest trend
in business
today there's all kinds of other things
you might talk about like crypto or I
don't know VR AR but ultimately what I
see the biggest trend being is it is
harder to be a scumbag and it is
therefore powerful to not be yeah the
radical transparency that we see
happening is preventing scumbags yeah
yeah that's that's a very good point but
there's also still a lot of yeah off
like offshoring and on and all these
other ways of but he's like you said
crypto will potentially help with that
radical transparency and there's a lot
of technological solutions that are
coming a plated to decrease the the
increase rather radical radical
transparency decrease scumbag that's
fine like that and that's very important
very true and conscious capitalism has
been a huge you know shoutout to
Alexander makovan and and you know
conscious capitalism we love you guys
very much there's that is a whole very
important movement in the direction of
really thinking about how we engage with
our employees how we engage with our
customers how we do what we can to give
back to to the world that is that has
helped us make what we've built yeah a
reality so it's interesting that we talk
about emotion because an empathy and and
the importance of that because you know
you're also doing that with mutiny now
which you know we'll get to but it's
like this emotional tie to your to your
to your animal to your cat and and okay
so even prior to unpacking that you know
how did you become who you are with this
tagline heroic power of game conscious
cama fication like what led will them to
that yeah well so I grew up as I said in
an extremely artistic family and I think
I think you know that the thing that I'm
most grateful for where I would say I'm
actually entitled is that love that they
gave me in that support that they gave
me because that's not something that
everybody gets so I think the first
place it started was with this family
and with the just amount of support and
exploration that they encouraged so I
was trying all kinds of things you
I was a diver of building stuff doing
construction I was constantly though
crafting and constantly interested in
the emerging trend of the tech world you
know it was already there but I'm a 90s
kids so there certainly was already a
tech world but it wasn't quite to the
extremity that it was already and what
actually changed is just for fun I built
a game when I was fifteen and addicting
games.com one of those old flash
websites bought it for 500 bucks and so
you know 500 hours is gonna get too much
but as a 15 year old I was like like
this is something happened and since
then it sort of I've been channeling the
creative energies that I've always had
into this field of games and then when I
moved out to California for Lumosity a
little forest years ago from where I'm
from Connecticut so I was an East
Coaster yeah yeah yeah did Rhode Island
for ya Rhode Island for school it was
Roger Williams University ah Williams
ubers yeah place back yeah Connecticut
and bulging parents were designers you
see teachers theatre teachers theatre
teachers so okay so there was a very
like humanities and arts
yes sides of both of the teaching and
you had a great amount of unconditional
love growing up which I totally agree is
such a cool you know principle of
parenting that makes powerful it is
powerful people yeah yeah so so for
instance the reason that I chose that
word like power heroic power of games
it's sort of presumptuous and it's sort
of masculine but the reason that I go
for it is because what-what conscious
capitalism I would say the biggest thing
I took away from them is it is totally
okay to make money and in our in our
especially in America in this
capitalistic society that is how power
flows if you want power money is often
involved and I think you know what
attracted me to and why I came up with
this conscious gamification thing is
games are this powerful motivator and
can be used in
really negative ways there are examples
of it being you know used to create
diction used to to influence people to
do crazy awful things but I think it can
also be used to create good for the
world and because once again people
genuinely care about companies that
genuinely care about them to use to make
a lot of money - yeah yeah that that
that is so so important um you know and
and that's interesting because that kind
of took you you know in your in your
youth when you started getting involved
in games and then you realize that like
when you moved to the Bay you got
involved in Lumosity and it's very
interesting because then you realize
this like really this crazy heroic power
because this is like really working on
our mental health and well-being games
that you do that and so yes it's about
now this transition of the Bay Area
doing that and then getting the immune
mean yes oh yeah absolutely so yeah I
would say Lumosity is one of the you
know one of my foundational moments I
started working with them on children's
games and then transitioned into you
know they're more standard games I've
been a game developer for them so it's
both engineering and actually you know
conceptualizing and and sort of leading
product but of course these are actual
games they're not they are products but
they're they're primarily games so I
think you know what Lumosity gave me is
there's a concept in the gaming world
called serious games
I actually don't love that term just
because it's not very specific you know
if I just said serious games you
wouldn't know that I was even saying a
term you'd just be like oh yeah serious
game but regardless there there's a
whole there's a big move and attention
to learn is that what that means so not
it is very wide it's basically you know
when you say games and I actually
resisted the gaming industry for a while
for this reason when you say games you
often don't think of any serious intent
there you know this is a thing for
pleasure and that's it and this is the
thing to pass the time you know it's a
waste of energy even that's a
perspective that a lot of people have on
games so serious games it's a movement
of people trying to I would say two big
things one see games as an art form
which I would absolutely argue it is yes
and to use the
in ways use this power of games I think
you know we as an industry are starting
to realize we know some stuff you know
we have spent 40-plus years figuring out
how to get people to do something that
they don't have to do you know you have
to pay your taxes you have to come to
work but you don't have to play a game
and yet on average people are spending
the status I think it's 6.2 hours a week
a gamer is spending six point two hours
a week playing a game and so why do they
do that
what I would argue and a lot of other
people in the gamification field you Kai
chow is my favorite would argue is
basically we have learned how to
motivate people and influence people to
to do something and so this conscious
gamification this movement to the Bay
Area is ok so I have this ability to get
people to do something Lumosity has this
ability because there's this higher
purpose to their games you know you are
educating you are learning and so you
play the games despite the fact that
there are much better games out there as
far as entertainment value because they
have this higher purpose and so that's
what I mean by the heroic power of games
you have this ability to motivate people
to do things and coupling that with
something positive with positive
intention makes it incredibly
motivational incredibly powerful and and
I think you know that's where the
country is moving and that's where I
think games can be used ads where they
can be moved to that's such a good point
is that you if you if people are already
spending you know 6.2 hours a week on on
games that there's a there's like we
were talking about this bell curve
earlier with like potentially like
malevolent actors that are they're just
trying to hook people in to like get
them to do meaningless potentially
things and and that are also highly
addicting that are potentially bad for
the health to keep of sedentary all kind
of stuff and then there's you know then
there's these really part of the power
of games I like that way more than you
know serious games but like you got to
say it with that energy enthusiasm that
you say with the power of game yeah the
power it's it's beautiful and when you
say it that way you can really give
people to think on you know
masa T or Miu and me these these games
that give us these that can that can
help us live better more filling lives
or that can even potentially get us to
better understand things like big
history or things like you know how we
ended up even beginning to these eight
billion humans on this rock who
innovated all these things that we see
around us every day so there's games
that can kind of expand our our
awareness of reality
yeah and I love thinking about that and
that's hopefully what we'll see with
some of the virtual and augmented
reality yes well very looking forward to
that
you know okay as you you know you have
we have this cool yeah graphic on on yes
right here so yeah teach us teach us
about how this is both you know that
that consciously implication plus plus
the hero power of games yes yeah so this
so first of all if you are a conscious
capitalist or you know them well you'll
see that very much inspired by them I
was trying to this is the first stab the
sort of version 1.0 of conscious
gamification I I have this very personal
connection to that symbol in the middle
the Grail the Grail the Grail and you
know what one of my one of them can get
when you achieve achievement when you
get there so one of the you know one of
one of the things that brings me a lot
of joy is sort of making the world a
fantasy you know and and I think what
finally clicked for me is that's what
games do the reason you play a game is
because it is your fantasy it gives you
a sense of meaning it gives you sense of
purpose it gives you autonomy as all
money all these different little parts
and you get to play this role of versus
watching a movie where you're
experiencing someone else's
interpretation of that of that same
story so this is recognizing that
ability and the Grail yes is the is the
heroic purpose we're going somewhere
with significant value and then it's
basically the the different areas of
expertise that combine to to make
conscious gamification the heroic power
of games something powerful so first of
all just game design by itself is really
powerful there's a reason that chess has
been around since we can possibly
remember we don't have written records
of the first you know the first time
chess was played products I think are
are the reason I have products in there
is because that's our current language
or capitalistic society products or how
we talk to each other how we sell to
each other
empathy is what I've been talking about
with this sort of more emotional
designing it is what I think the next
step and there's already a lot of
evidence for this towards product design
especially in emotional design so the
what turned me on to this my talk at GDC
which I think we'll get to was about
empathic design which is a term coined
by a woman named Danielle credit and
she's the head of the empathy lab at
Google she's basically trying to use
empathy to teach AI to be better AI like
so so empathy is already working its way
in and it's in many industries and what
I what I want to impress above all else
is that it really is a superpower like
being able to understand your user and
figure out exactly why your user is
feeling the way they are allows you to
create things that you couldn't possibly
create and then consciousness is this is
inspired by conscious capitalism again
that's there because I think we have a
responsibility to create things that are
not hooking people in are not addicting
them and once again this is another
strength it is not just a call to arms
or something if you look at Facebook for
instance I would argue that it's falling
out of style right now and that they
have a lot of things to figure out right
now and one of the reasons that they're
falling out of style among among many
the way to explain it yeah is because
they've been abusing their users if you
if you just think about motivational
levels which is so gamification is
applying game design principles to get
somebody to do something basically and
really it's just human motivation so if
you look at motivation if you just look
at Facebook through the lens of
motivation they are very good at getting
you to stay in their system right they
have spent years making it making it
really enticing to stay in facebook and
spend a lot of time in facebook but what
they're doing and what I think they
haven't really noticed yet and this is
why conscious gamification has a
strength
is there slowly motivating people to
leave them mm-hmm they're building the
motivation to eliminate that time period
it's from you know I look at the way we
treat addiction in our country like if
I'm addicted to cigarettes I'm gonna
have 20 people in my life who are really
pumped to help me lose cigarettes and so
why would you not why would the same
thing on happen for a product and I
would argue it is it's starting to
happen this is very important point so
when you don't follow a conscious
gamification when you don't follow a
paradigm of heroic power of games where
that grails in the center mm-hmm and you
have to have these components that you
have to have the the game the product
that empathy the consciousness all
together when when when that comes
together then your game continues in
style because you're motivating people
to have some sort of more meaning in
their life or more awareness expansion
that type of stuff when your product is
not following those principles it falls
out of style and then you see it kind of
in a similar way to like you know
cigarettes and I'm pretty sure that
Benioff said that Facebook was like a
cigarettes yeah it is yeah and no we're
drawing those conclusions already yeah
yeah it the filter bubble aspect to the
the advertising aspect the fact that
that's how they make the money then hook
you in and so then that this all these
things are a little added like cancers
to what could have potentially been a
heroic way of having civil discourse and
community and games oh I have the
perfect example for you so a lot of what
I'm talking about right now I just want
to give credit where credit is due you
Kai chow
he wrote actionable gamification if
you're interested in how to improve your
product through game design principles
get that book he's amazing he he talks
about white hat versus black hat
gamification basically gamification at
the positive of gamification that's more
negative and he says that there is a
place for both and I would argue that
there in fact is teach us about why
there's a place for white it's like
positive black is Ning exactly so so my
first example is almost entirely white
gamification and I also like it because
it is you wouldn't you wouldn't think
this website is gamified and that's
Wikipedia so it's gamified so this is
one of the problems with gamification
people tend to think like there's points
yeah and then so this is a youkai
chuckles of PBL's yeah exactly he calls
it the PBL's the points badges and
leaderboards and that's what that's
gamification is kind of a bad word at
this point in product land and that's
because a bunch of companies paid a lot
of money to a lot of people who told
them that they could make them a lot of
money and then nothing happened because
people didn't get deep with it they were
like I'm gonna slap some points on a
subpar product and then that's good
enough
so with Wikipedia it is not obviously
gamified but it is and I'll tell you why
so if you were to randomly insert a
swear word onto a random page on
Wikipedia and we take on average 1.7
minutes to be removed yeah that is not
automation yeah that is a volunteer
finding that swear word and removing it
yeah your edit they're like manually
looking through your edits - exactly
especially when you don't have when you
haven't built up your credit score yes
and Wikipedia so yes so this is someone
who has signed up for probably I don't
actually know how this works but this is
my assumption how it works
they've probably signed up for like
notifications this page has been edited
and then they feel responsibility to go
edit it and they remove this swear word
so this person is spending hours a day
voluntarily no money no attribution
policing Wikipedia and it's not there is
no actual like extrinsic motivation for
that the reason that they're doing it is
because they are protecting the
knowledge base of the human race yes
they're doing it because they have
empowerment they're doing it because
they have meaning and that's where I
would argue it's gamified why we play a
big RPG game because we have meaning
where the hero of time or whatever and
so they're not giving you like points
but they're absolutely gamifying their
product or absolutely giving you the
sense of meaning interesting so their
delivery wikipedia is delivering a sense
of meaning because you are a warrior for
the foundation of knowledge
and there's nothing wrong with that so
that's what this is this is saying so
short-term you can absolutely hook
somebody in and get them addicted but
long-term that's a that's it's not gonna
work
so what I'm saying here is I can use
game design Theory human motivation to
get you to use a product and have it be
equitable for all of us you have us all
be happy about that
and have you experienced no negatives
for that yes so that's the white versus
black right interest and there is black
out gamification so my other example is
Nike Plus you know they they are a much
more literal example of gamification you
have points and levels and badges and
all that stuff flowing running for
running so this was I think they just do
it with your phone now but for a while
they they had a little like attachment
that was basically a you know counted
your steps right sort of Fitbit tight
fit bits actually a perfect example as
well if I got you I wouldn't use the
word addicted but if I gave you the same
kind of hooks that Facebook uses make
you feel kind of guilty for not running
or something like that give you a sense
of social pressure to keep running I
would argue that's fine you know because
it's improving your lifestyle and unless
it's subtracting from other parts of
your life yeah yeah that's actually good
so that's where blackhat gamification
can actually work its way in okay so you
call blackhat gamification maybe a
little bit of social pressure to maybe
get someone to not buy the second ice
cream of the day yeah so there's Ron
yeah so there's a the this you Chi Chows
terminology so I'm just using it to for
anybody who knows it there's a he calls
it his calluses framework which I like
it basically has eight key human
motivators one half is all the more
negative stuff that's basically preying
upon our insecurities is generally how
you would think about it so social
pressures on there you know making you
feel obligated to do something hooking
you into it
that's that's black hat versus meaning
is a perfect example of white hat I am
called to action I'm not like compelled
or manipulated into it mmm-hmm
that make sense yeah yeah whoa yeah this
is extremely powerful yeah
now as you know as you're giving these
examples of of white and black hat
gamification and I'm sure you know
eventually the ucae child like we would
love to figure out a way to feature this
is of him yeah okay on the show that
would be super fun but you know it's
kind of is teaching me a bit more about
how you got your you know your framework
for what you're making now and I'm glad
that you did this you're like you are a
conscious game developer like you are
you're like that you're like the
pinnacle of conscious game development I
love that I call myself the conscious
games guy the conscious game that's good
that's so good and you're also you know
you're spreading the message at GDC when
you were when you're speaking and when
you're when you're hanging out with
other game developers you're spreading
the conscious game development and so
all right so now take us into how
applying this and everything you've
learned got you to the haha moment of
okay I'm gonna do Moo and me mm-hmm
yeah well so I'll tell you why me and me
started it started before this basically
I have always had animals but my family
we moved a lot but primarily we were in
like really you know we were in the
middle of a forest right now for
instance there's like two thousand acres
of forest around us so we've always had
animals they've always been outdoor
animals Fez who's featured in that
commercial you just saw the little
tuxedo cat is my first cat that I own
myself he's my first indoor because I
live in the city and he's my first solo
cat so really what happened is I got
this cat I noticed that it was really
obvious happen thank you I noticed that
it was really obvious that he missed me
he'd literally waiting at the door for
me to come through you know and my level
of guilt really was just escalating
through the roof so one weekend I like
took these really cheap toys and
soldered some wires into them so that
could plug them into the wall a fez so
that I could plug them into the wall and
and leave them running and actually
program them to turn on and off so
giving him something to do while I was
away basically and that was just to me
at the time it was nothing more than
like a silly fun weekend project but a
bunch of my friends a bunch of my cat
friends freaked out about it wanted like
actual blueprints and then my business
mentor who I had told a couple dozen
ideas to by that point flipped out will
say he thought it was incredible yeah
and so was I think I think it's all the
best companies go was it was built out
of necessity it was like oh I feel so
bad about this little cat and I round
there I remembered that I was a game
developer so games for cats that's a
great story the Genesis story of yeah
yeah okay and so then you you know as
you realize that you've pieced this the
system together and you're like
interesting I want to now bring this
forth into an actual product yes - tell
us about yeah so it was it was still
mostly for feds for a while it was
mostly just like okay I could probably
build him some games and I think it was
really it was actually a Tony Robbins
event I think where it really got real
you know I was considering it good yeah
we love Tony yeah it was a UPW oh yeah
so Tony is fascinated you know I think I
think likening him to a cult is totally
legit there's gonna be parts where
you're like but there's good that
there's a lot of really good stuff yeah
so I went to one of those sort of
without knowing what it was and just the
level of motivation that you experienced
from that and and the other thing is the
number of really amazing people that I
met there who I told the silly idea to
and then reacted extremely positively
yes I think was what really sealed it I
was like okay so I gotta figure how to
quit my job and start a company for cats
never would have expected it but man the
amount of joy that this brings me yes
when you wake up everyday and you're
just like wow yeah I'm like what I love
and it feels great yeah yeah what even
then they're still down so of course
those yeah but we got it yeah we
persevered yeah so this is a Toni term
push versus pull motivation you can you
can push yourself into something for an
extended period of time but much like
blackhat gamification eventually that's
going to fail you know you're incurring
debt on yourself kind of versus pull
motivation is something that pulls you
forward it's that sort of higher purpose
it's a meaning and I just want to
impress here because I just had a
personal conversation with a friend that
I don't I don't think it exists where
you could possibly be pulled all the
time I think that that's a lie and that
people who say you know you got to find
the thing that never feels like work
it's gonna feel like work sometimes
that's okay yeah you just gotta push
through those moments yeah it's a good
way to put it yeah so you're like
pulling towards this higher destiny yeah
but through this social fabric that has
these that has these like these these
the ups and downs that you you know that
you gotta you know also push yourself
through those because that's how you
persevere you you're gonna have down
days yes and that's normal and that
doesn't mean that you're wrong about
what you're working on yeah that's great
yeah yeah yeah okay so now you know this
emotional connection like was fuzzy you
know you were like you know the cat your
cat's like waiting there for you right
you're just like I want to be able to
connect with my cat and during the day
mm-hm and engage with it in a way that
both increases the health of our
connection yeah my health at work the
cat's health when they're moving and
playing so tell us about how then that
gets you to the Muni development yeah so
I had a kind of magical moment I had set
up a webcam to test if he was playing
these original toys and I turned on the
webcam and then I was controlling it via
remote so I had I could actually it was
a computer that could actually make do
stuff right so I put on a video of some
birds and I'm watching the webcam and he
like wakes up and turns around and walks
over the camera and is standing there
directly in front of me and and that
like dopamine hit mm-hm and that sense
of
like I'm giving him something yeah you
know I feel less bad about him being
alone yeah it was a huge moment so this
was I think that was sort of that was a
true Genesis moment where I went okay so
this is what I'm trying to deliver
there's a little prototype name for this
there were a few but one of my favorites
was fluffy love fluffy love because you
know San Francisco but that was actually
one of the reasons I would avoid it yeah
but so you know that's that's what I'm
trying to explain when you when you hug
an animal there's such a there's a quote
that I don't quite remember the whole
thing but you know what short little
lives our animals live and they spend
most of it waiting for us to come home
you know like it is it is a gift that
they give us the information and so
there's a sense of responsibility but
there's also just this great sense of
gratitude of like love and appreciation
so that's what I'm what I was trying to
create and then I think because of this
lens of Lumosity I realized you know
nobody is kind of existing in this
animal behavioral space there are people
who are doing things that are kind of
similar and are touching on many of the
same you know problems that same feeling
of guilt when your animals alone but
there's no one who's really who has that
sense of purpose that sense of meaning
to expand our understanding of animals
at large and so I think that was another
big moment was okay so I have something
that'll be kind of interesting profess
to do and I'm a lot when he's away when
I'm away when he's alone and not yet but
I'll be able to remotely control it or
make it do fun things and I'll be able
to play with him remotely but what if
I'm also learning about him delivering
me as a user more content about this
animal but delivering humanity a greater
understanding of animals in general and
that was I think where that was what the
GDC talk was about and that was also
what what flipped me into this conscious
gamification land I was like okay so I
can use a game to have this higher
purpose for my users and to basically
under the radar slip some empathy to
them yes you know this animal is more
just an animal and I know you already
know that but let me show you yeah yeah
this a whole new way you know fascinated
with time and so when you think about
just the 16 hours that we have awake and
then if you're going somewhere to work
for eight plus your commute yeah you
know you're really your cat or dog or
you know your animal holding like three
to six hours of your day maybe yeah yeah
yeah hopefully it's like 600 Polly is
that long but that's you know that's
crazy that they're spending more time
without you than with you that they are
literally yeah yeah I mean including
sleep yeah and yeah sleep yeah yeah
correct so then that really also kind of
makes it makes us further realize how
much we really need to build these
platforms that that that helped give us
a greater emotional tie to not only you
know our connection to the animal but
also to their health our health you know
that's that's that's very good okay so
now now you're you're doing crazy things
with this because I until today I didn't
actually think that we had you know cat
behaviorist and that oh yes oh yes this
exists and so we can actually study cat
behavior and then do things like you
were teaching me about their schedule
right so that they're if you're feeding
them at 9:00 a.m. they're gonna wake you
up to be fed at 9:00 they're waiting for
you at the door because they have this
idea that you're coming back so then you
you can study cat behavior and
potentially see when something is wrong
going wrong so yeah so teach us about
the cat science yes as well yes so that
was in large part what the GDC talk was
about one of the first things that I did
so so there was a format that I found
when looking at empathic designs this
that is an existing term you can google
that there's a format called empathy
mapping which is a super simple little
thing and this is primarily what I was
delivering this was a thing that I
hadn't seen at least in the game design
world and so that's what I brought to
GDC and then I I told him his personal
story about applying it to cats and then
how it wound up being really useful for
humans too but basically when you do a
typical user test and
whose product monitor games minded has
done this before they've sat down with
her user they've talked to them
preferably like in the space where
they're using the product and all that
stuff most of the time what you're
actually getting is what they're doing
with the product and then what they're
saying to you and so my argument is
basically that talking is kind of a
limiting factor because for cat
obviously I can't talk to it I have no
idea what's actually running through its
head and so the only lens that I have to
look at what's working for the cat is
what it's actively doing and then the
other problem is I can't do empathic
design I can't put myself in the cat's
shoes because I'm not a cat so I learned
all kinds of things primarily through a
cat behaviorist also just through doing
a lot of reading cat sense and cat lies
are both very good books if you need a
cat book and most of these things wound
up improving actual product actual
product like retention and engagement so
in the talk I go I about how I applied
this process to go from 20% cat
engagement to 62 which is where we're at
right now and that's a take that with a
grain of salt because we have no way to
differentiate if that's a user a human
hitting the games at this point if the
humans playing it that's fine so 62% of
our games have some kind of engagement
now where as it used to be like 20 30
percent so cat behaviorists are a thing
their primary duty it well is to study
just cats in general but those are my
cats by the way from years ago I just
wanted everyone loves their cats yeah
how many do you have wrong there were
two - they escaped and
I never seen them again oh they're
heartbreaking yeah yeah yeah yeah cats
are so so I think the primary thing
about cats and and what I experience
from these cat behaviourists to
understand is we spent I don't know
10,000 years domesticating dogs and you
can see the result of that dogs love us
you know they're the they're the
two-year-old who you can do no wrong
they're just in love with you no matter
what a cat is still in large part a wild
animal and we've only really been
domesticating them for maybe a couple
hundred years they kind of showed up
because we had rats in our grain storage
and we were like well I guess if they
eat the rats that's okay we'll just
leave him and that was really our
relationship with them for a long time
and so that was the birth of the
domestication of the cat I was the worst
as a domesticated rats in Greece or
grain storage yet and so so this cat
behaviorist that they're the people who
are who are trying to explain that who
are trying to what they often wind up
doing is they'll be they'll be the
person who helps you have two cats get
along you know if two cats are fighting
cats are traditionally very hard to
connect cat to cat you know they they
are territorially based and it's because
they're still wild animals and because
there are very few species of cats that
are actually socialized you know it's
like lions and then the ancient ancestor
of the domesticated cat and that's
basically it
so the behaviorists are the people who
are to use my own terminology trying to
use empathy to understand cats they're
trying to get in cats heads and so
finding those people became a really
pivotal part to designing products for
them because I could guess it what's
going through a cat's head but I cannot
figure out what they're thinking and I
cannot figure out what they're feeling
unless I have somebody who who truly
understands that yeah yes thank you Ron
so now to partner up with you know cat
behaviorist to run more this this
underlying science as well as empathy
and emotion that we that we're gaining
from that that's very beautiful and the
way that that can augment our you know
communities and and one world I love
that you know underlying there now you
know you did
Capcom last year and then that kind of
gave you a big ramp up and now Pat
Kahn's coming up again this year you're
gonna give that another big ramp up get
more average monthly users get more
you're gonna your weight so now that's
going up in June but then you're also
trying to figure out how to take the
next steps with getting the the kind of
building out the model of how to engage
the people that are using the platform
right so yeah so tell us about what
those next steps are yes
so the the big steps coming up are the
tablet if the product hasn't
significantly changed in a while now and
that's because we're figuring out really
foundational questions so the big thing
to change they're coming up and look
forward to it is interspecies
multiplayer is what I call it so this
automatic capability is great people
think it's cool but what I have found
for most of my users is they generally
just play in person and they think it's
really cool to have this interesting
unique experience with their cat so what
I'm gonna be offering is what does a
game look like that has been
intentionally designed for a human to
play with a cat so competitively for
instance you know imagine like mario a
platformer where the cat is the obstacle
you are controlling mario and the cats
attacking mario and you have to try to
dodge the cat yeah or there could be
some some games that are you know that
you're played together like it's
actually an advantage to have a cat
somehow allow it game so that's gonna be
the neck the immediate next step those
are in very interesting yeah it's
currently totally free to use where it
will always have a freemium version you
can always use it for free but there
will be paid content that's going to be
out for this next cat con which is the
end of june and then the the big step
after that is actually to design a cat
game console which is gonna be
fascinating it basically means a tablet
that is dedicated to you and me it
doesn't do anything else besides that
but it has some considerations that make
it much better for the cat
and then way down the road this is like
three to five years we'll actually step
into physical products that are you know
it's swinging a cat toy around or
whatever but sticking with this with our
roots as a game company first yeah yep
there it is yeah look at the look at the
design of that that's great
and a fifth anniversary of tat con it's
so great that this this happens at least
there's you know there's a respect
towards this animal we've domesticated
to try and yeah make things better now
yeah interspecies multiplayers
fascinating you're giving me all this
like all these ideas about you know how
to play you know against cat compete but
also play with the cat like yeah maybe
you're doing some like you're running on
like there's obstacles and the cats the
one that's trying to get rid of the
obstacle as well your competitor there's
all these interesting sorts of styles of
games there's cat console with like the
dedicated components to better see the
cat through the camera and incorporate
all the different aspects that are gonna
make it like a whole huge like console
and experience for the cat so also you
know I was asking a bit about this
earlier I'm really fascinated with with
seeing what we could do to make this
underlying emotional connection and and
scientific understanding of our
relationship with dogs
and as well so hopefully you know down
the line you said that maybe they'll
come in multiple years down the line
yeah to touch on that quickly tablets
are where we're starting what I always
say is it's not the best solution it's
the most accessible one that I know how
to create the when we move into physical
actual physical toys that have the same
sort of theme automatic and remote
control play tracking what the animals
doing that'll be when we can actually
get the dogs
mostly because we'll destroy a tablet
yeah yeah which is one of the primary
concerns of people that are used my
tablet's gonna get destroyed in it now
okay I want to loop this all into kind
of the first things that you were
explaining so we have this complex world
we have our desire to be more
and pathetic to create a better social
fabric with like conscious
interdependent capitalism things like
this what are maybe these you know skill
sets that you highly recommend that we
develop and teach children as we go into
this exponential technology age I so I
am it's amazing how quickly you fall out
of style with knowing what's in the
education system already so I've been
really impressed with the if the amount
that mindfulness has already worked its
way in that's one that I would recommend
if you if you don't already meditate
find somewhere to do it doing it
yourself is great once you know what
you're doing but until then find
somewhere to do it having those people
around you is gonna make a huge
difference the other thing is is empathy
you know that's that's what I call my so
I literally gamify my own life and
that's what I call Maya quest is
creating empathy finding leaders of love
as I call them people who want to see a
more loving world mmm-hmm and the reason
that I like that is because you know
there are two primary motivators if you
boil it way down to our most primitive
selves it's fear and it's love it's joy
maybe there's a better word for it but
it's it's good and bad right and we are
driven so much today by fear and fear
only really leads to ruin it doesn't
have any productive outcome unless
you're literally escaping from a tiger
or something you know there's no reason
to be to focus on fear so what I think
people need to focus on is that
emotional connection I think especially
men as I was saying at the beginning
have had a long time being socialized
that they should suppress their emotions
and that it is a strength to do so and
what I'm telling you and hopefully
starting to convince you of is that that
is a weakness it is it is weak to not be
able to feel your emotions you are a
worse designer especially for design
especially for creativity you are far
worse if you are not emotional but also
just day to day you know whatever you do
with your life you can be a construction
worker and if you aren't emotionally
feeling out the situation then you
aren't going to experience the full
spectrum it's it's a it's a sense and so
if you're cutting off that sense that
you are weakening yourself so that's
that's what I think that's at least my
own vision and my own quest to bring to
the world is a sense of love an amount
and being emotional convincing men
especially and I keep saying then
especially because I think women have
the leg up here that it's okay to be
emotional and then it is an advantage to
be emotional and and yeah I think that's
a that's my primary oh yeah those are
beautiful yeah the Met the meditation is
so crucial and for equanimity and for
peace and for love and compassion
gratitude and all these other really
important traits and then as well as and
also like contemplation of our own
looks like authoring of our future with
meditation as well I'm envisioning that
destiny and then and then making it come
true yes at the same time as I agree
with you that when you're not feeling
this full spectrum of emotion that holy
cow are we missing out on our ability to
create better our ability to design
better our ability to you know feel what
someone else is feeling and how like go
behind their eyes and see the story of
their life and why they got to where
they are today instead of just you know
yelling and like going Krita knots it's
just yeah I like how you you make that
really clear like when you want to get
to world peace in that direction
yeah that's these are the practices yeah
yeah to go there okay will them couple
questions on the way out of this show
that we like to ask okay the first
question is are we alone in the cosmos I
don't think so
at least I hope not so something that
you just mentioned is this sort of
authoring of your future and I think
that there's so much strengths of that
there's ultimately your entire life
comes down to decisions and I decided
that there are other beings besides
humans in the world and then
statistically and not in the world
excuse me maybe in the world I don't
know in the universe but statistically
if you want to get if you want to go
there it's really unlikely that we are
the only beings in the universe and
there's all kinds of
examples of this and different
explanations for why people think one
way or another but regardless the
universe is really big and so it's
really unlikely that we would be the
only place to create life so yes
short answer playground earth yeah yeah
one of many potential playgrounds
this is simulation so are we in a
simulation
that's another decision and I would say
I haven't decided
i I think that one way or another I kind
of so I kind of don't like the idea of
us being in a simulation but it's
another one that statistically mm-hmm
it's more likely that we are why don't
you like the idea because it takes away
from some of that autonomy that sense of
self takes the fun out of it but so my
decision there is I you know I don't let
that affect me other way yeah I think
it's very conceivable that we are but
one way or another I'm live in this life
yeah you're gonna level up regardless
yeah yeah I'm almost to level to level -
yeah - yeah forever in in universe
kindergarten yeah okay and then the last
question what is the most beautiful
thing in the world
oh great question
I think and this is you know a very
biased opinion but I think the most
beautiful thing in the world
is somebody who is passionate about
something and goes out of their way to
go make it happen because that is how
humanity moves forward you know if you
do the same thing that everybody else
does the best you can expect is exactly
what everybody else got and so you know
I I have so much value for being a big
weirdo me too and so I just I find it so
beautiful when someone goes you know
what I'm gonna do it this way and then
they go do it I love those people
especially when they're loving and
caring yeah yeah yeah let's such such a
good answer yes is taking the a being an
outlier in the direction of human
progress taking like the burden on your
on yourself of wanting to change the
world for the better for the next
generations and convincing people that
that old map the old code isn't as good
as this new code and that getting them
in that direction it's very very
beautiful
that's like especially when you manage
to stay connected to society and and
have love and emotion exactly yeah
outlier in the loving and emotion right
sense of building a better world yes yes
this has been super enriching I've had a
great time they may feel you're coming
ah thank you
absolutely yes it's been lovely to hear
that thanks everyone for tuning in we
greatly appreciate you we would love to
hear your thoughts in the comments below
about the things that we talked about on
this episode also we would love for you
to check out
Willems links below go and check out mu
and me go check out his website his
Instagram check out that below share
share it with other cat lovers you know
get more people using this and had
experiencing this really deep emotional
connection please please go and share
that around huge shout out to Ron Vargas
for producing and directing we love you
very much thank you thank you
and everyone support the artists and
entrepreneurs that you believe in
simulation support us our links are
below helped us grow and go and build
the future manifest your dreams into the
world we love you very much thank you
and we will
see you soon peace
[Music]